[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight we have a newly released
document for you this evening to
classify just a few hours ago it was
written during the final few moments
literally of the Obama administration on
inauguration day for the National
Security Adviser it reveals what you may
have suspected FBI director Jim Comey
considered himself more powerful than
any elected American president in the
name of defending democracy in other
words Comey rejected democracy's main
tenets and put himself completely in
charge no election necessary it's all a
chilling glimpse of how things actually
work in Washington we've got the details
just ahead but first for three years our
entire professional class hectored us
about the overweening threat we
supposedly faced from Russia Russia you
remember had somehow hacked American
democracy during the 2016 presidential
campaign Russian agents had infiltrated
our government at the highest levels
honourable former naval officers people
who seemed honorable anyway like Carter
Paige were in fact secret Stooges of
Vladimir Putin's and they were working
toward diabolical ends with political
consultants like Roger stone it was all
hiding in plain sight and it was working
forget Mexico or Saudi Arabia or the
United Arab Emirates or many other
countries it was Russia more than any
other place that threatened America's
sovereignty that was actually in control
of our foreign policy that's the story
they told us none of it was ever
plausible in fact it was completely
absurd it was obviously absurd there was
never any evidence that it was true but
they kept saying day after tiresome day
until it's stuck until every single CNN
viewer every single PBS donor every
subscriber to the New Yorker magazine
believed it as a matter of religious
faith Russia hacked our democracy was
almost on their totebags it was their
mantra the Russians exploited a massive
backdoor into the foundation of our
democracy
Moscow's attack on American democracy
the work by Russian agents to try to
destabilize
and democracy everything you need to
know about the threat to our democracy
you have Republicans who are silent and
seemingly okay with this kind of attack
on our democracy there is no question
that Russia attacked us for tax ladies
and gentlemen our Constitution attack on
the integrity of our elections an attack
on our democracy the first time we've
had an adversary attack us that we have
not responded these people brandishing
their silly credentials like we have a
moral obligation to listen to them
because they know what they're talking
about they were fools reading their
stupid talking points again and again
like they were real but they were doing
it for a reason the beauty of the Russia
fable was that it allowed these people
our ruling class to ignore the huge
number of actual problems the United
States faced problems that in many cases
they cost or at very least failed to
solve the drug addiction crisis that has
killed tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands over time the border that is
essentially open a disappearing middle
class the core of our country the rise
of China and then of course any number
of counterproductive Foreign Wars that
should have ended long ago for three
years nobody in Washington talked about
any of this in fact failing to worry
about Russia exclusively invited
suspicion on you if you wanted for
example American troops home for the
Middle East or if you wondered aloud why
no one seemed to care when your twenty
three-year-old niece died of a fentanyl
OD that might be evidence you two were
colluding with Russia and that's not an
exaggeration Susan Rice who seemed smart
she went to Stanford admitted later that
she decided Michael Flynn was a Russian
spy because he talked too much about
China and that's what Russian spies do
now Donald Trump was elected no one
thought he would be precisely because he
talked about issues like these the ones
that mattered that was a massive threat
so they derailed to a large extent his
first term agenda using a hoax concocted
by the administration he replaced who
benefited from this all the people who
thought it up but nobody benefited more
than the Chinese government
well our leaders in Washington wasted
literally years accusing each other of
working for Putin China grew more
powerful it grew closer to replacing the
United States as the world's dominant
nation but the time this version of
coronavirus spread west from Wuhan China
was calling many of the shots
internationally we didn't even know it
until the crisis hit for example the US
has given far more money than any other
nation to the World Health Organization
and yet strangely our ally Taiwan still
is not a member of the w-h-o why is that
only one reason China doesn't want them
to be and so they're not china is
effectively in control of the WHL want
proof
watch the director of the World Health
Organization repeat the most ridiculous
Chinese propaganda as if we're all
completely true with an utterly straight
face mMmmm that's right as always if you
want to know who's really in charge
watch the lies they tell Chinese
government is to be congratulated for
the extraordinary measures it has taken
to contain the outbreak China is
actually setting a new standard for
outbreak response and it's not an
exaggeration
so the new standard the fake doctor you
just saw is promoting in the end created
the worst economic calamity since the
Great Depression a calamity that China
benefited immensely from China may be
the only country on the globe that has
become stronger in the face of this no
doubt the Chinese government was pleased
with their puppets at the w-h-o
accomplished last night the president
knighted States released a letter to the
World Health Organization warning that
the US will suspend funding permanently
if the organization doesn't reform
itself right away and we knit self from
China we'll see if that happens either
way though the problem is much bigger
than just the World Health Organization
China's tentacles extend almost
everywhere in our society the Chinese
government is now deeply a meshed in
higher education in this country it's
not an overstatement a number of
university professors including one
today have been arrested for spying on
behalf of Beijing literally spies on
campus tenured spies China has profound
what's in Hollywood you know that in
professional sports we saw that last
year and in corporate America up and
down the chain the Chinese owned huge
amounts of real estate throughout this
country one of the reasons your kids
can't afford to live in our cities all
of this has changed our lives in
profound ways but all of it happened
with very little public notice why
because the people making it possible
didn't want to advertise that they were
getting very rich from it
every ambitious climber in corporate
America knows the rules now don't offend
Beijing and you could be rewarded the
head of Disney streaming service just
left to become CEO of tick-tock that's a
Chinese company that may appalled you
but in corporate America many are
envious they wish they were him
Washington hasn't been immune to this
either China's influences everywhere in
the capital city former Senator Joe
Lieberman lobbies for China now hard to
believe isn't it Samir Jain was a top
cybersecurity official for the Obama
administration now he lobbyist for
Huawei and those are just a couple of
the very few who followed the law and
actually registered under Farah as
foreign lobbyists hunter Biden never
bothered to do that
Biden worked hard to sell his access to
politicians in Washington presumably his
father the vice president chief among
them to investors who were getting rich
in China it was never a secret many
people in Washington knew exactly what
hunter Biden was doing and they didn't
say anything to anybody why because it
didn't seem weird to them it wasn't
strange so many other well-connected
people were doing the same thing selling
access to elected officials in
Washington to the Chinese Nancy Pelosi
still doesn't understand why any of this
is a big deal possi has spent decades
bowing to the Chinese government
even as she attacks this country is
racist and backward as she does
virtually every day of the week just the
other day Pelosi announced that no
conversation about China is legitimate
it's all a distraction let me just say
that what the president is saying about
China is interesting it's an interesting
diversion let's keep our focus on
meeting the needs of the American people
opening our economy yeah it's a
diversion
how many antibiotics do we make in this
country in the middle of a pandemic
let's see zero none all in China just a
diversion when you watch something like
policy statement a terrifying thought
creeps up from the back of your mind is
trying to now too strong to criticize is
our only option to submit maybe we'll
find out
even now there are certainly downsides
for anyone who dares say a negative word
about Beijing China is now threatening
to punish elected American officials who
dare to criticize the Chinese response
to coronavirus hard to believe they're
saying that out loud